him
you guys aren't getting tired
of kevin samuels i'm about to go back
to the apartment and
react to some videos so i was just gonna
see what you guys wanted me to do
this is kind of trash
i'm not it's like cookie dough like raw
cookie dough this one is not very good
it's like too sweet
but i'm really eat today so
i figured why not now i'm like super
thirsty though
um conor mcgregor savage moments i could
do that
um young papa killer kill him okay
react to jess pearl thanks eating on
camera i don't think i want to i'm not a
neat eater
like at all
kevin samuels is the goat
okay i do not like how low
this like these eyebrows do not match
and it bothers me
guys my hair was like down to here and i
loved it this lady cut off
all my hair this is what i get for going
to random hairstylists like 100 of the
time
what's queen brown i don't know what
that is
have i ever thought about going bald no
no i'm a lady
oh my god
if i shave my head bald i'll have less
problems and now i love
i want long long hair my hair just grows
so slow
no i really truly believe that every
girl is less attractive with
less hair there are girls that can pull
it off because they're like
exceptionally pretty but even like halle
berry
who like definitely pulls off short hair
i think if she had long hair would look
better
just my opinion though doesn't mean
anything
i don't want to go to chipotle for
dinner
[Music]
also i have like the super chat sound
i'm gonna start live streaming my
reactions when i get home
um
but if you guys ever want to like chat
donations to the channel
um i'd really appreciate it because i'm
we're trying to like
i'm trying to move out at some point
but only if you guys want to you guys
know i'm not like super pushy with that
stuff
this is it needs to go
so i'm from chicago originally like
chicago suburbs though not real chicago
oh my gosh this would be a cool tick
tock
you know what's crazy i have 800 000
followers on tick tock and like 15
000 on youtube and i'm starting to like
beat my tic tac videos
like almost in views which is kind of
nuts to me
i gotta get more people to subscribe to
be honest
i'm from chiraq no i'm not from chiraq i
am from
chicago suburbs very different from
chicago
i'll be a young boy white teeth
how tall am i i'm six foot
tommy lauren uh what like i think i did
react to her like feminist rant
my dress size no um i'm slightly
overweight that's what i would say
i don't need the people on here to roast
me
abba and preach i like album preach a
lot
like i probably need to lose like
20 pounds maybe i would say 20 pounds
um
from brazil that's crazy um
okay react to yo yo mama jokes
what would i give myself on a scale of
one to ten
um probably when i was younger i would
have said a six but i've have like more
wrinkles and i gained a little weight
it's probably five
[Music]
um
no flaws king
and plus i will say though kevin samuels
like attractiveness skill
i don't feel like represents the real
world because i would not so i would say
in a room of 10 like random people you
get out off of like the street beyonce
maybe like not now but like ten years
ago would have at least been a nine or a
ten
because he looks at like
um and same with like
i don't know the girls that he like you
have to remember like the majority of
americans are overweight so if you're
just like
not overweight that puts you a lot
higher
um do i want to work to pay significant
bills you guys are funny um i wouldn't
really
mind i really like like i really like
youtube and i like doing like creative
stuff
so um i really wouldn't mind
yeah like 70 yeah and that's what i'm
saying like
when he says like rank yourself a scale
of 1 to 10
i don't think his scale is like accurate
of if you took
10 like average 25 year old 24 year olds
you know what i'm saying
so
so i look i think that
it's not super accurate to like and i
mean
i'm sure in the cities it's like people
are more attractive and like hotter
but if you take just like normal people
in the world um would i ever consider
doing gaming
probably not i really don't like
oh my gosh i'm gonna have to end this
live soon because my phone's gonna die
me see if i can
get it to plug in this outlet in this
car
okay cool it's charging now we're good
but i'm chatting i'm really trying to
get in shape
it's funny actually watching kevin
samuels has made me want to lose weight
like i swear to god because i'll see
like him roast the women on there and
i'm like damn maybe i should get in
shape
i'm down five pounds this month so if i
keep going i'll be
in four months i'll be down 20 if i keep
it at that rate
so in basketball i was a center i'm
pretty tall
um i don't know anything about the
murder of xxx
and i don't want to say how much i weigh
but
my bmi is like
on the edge of like if i gained like
five to ten more pounds it'd be like
classifieds overweight
so i'm trying to get to the like
athletic category so i'm outside of like
normal
um
you got two young papi
at six two you don't look overweight
well people actually i weigh more than
people
usually guess because
i gain most of my weight like in my
stomach and when you gain weight in your
stomach
if you hide your stomach like
it's like pretty easy to make yourself
look a little bit thinner
um because i just i don't really gain it
in like my arms and my legs
uh my main focus in my youtube channel
is to gain
subscribers how much do i bet so i'm
actually pretty strong the last time i
did a bench
max out i was at um let me think so i
was
i was two and a half pounds away from a
plate so
two and a half pounds away from 25 on
each side would be 50.
um 45 for the bar
wait no no i was two and a half pounds
away from 45s on each side
so 45 plus 45 is 90 um
100 121 oh my god i can't do math
i can't do math what's 45 times 3
minus 5 that's what i'm doing
whatever that is that's what that's
where
that's where my benchmax was
i can't do math i'm like actually really
terribly bad
yeah see 130 pounds for the bench yeah
that's my bench
and the most i've ever done for deadlift
is 285.
um i don't think i could do that right
now because i've been in la
um so
i would guess i'm like 250 for deadlift
if i like did it today
that's my guess
so one 130 is my benchmax
you would guess i'm a 160 yeah you guys
are very off for my weight
that's
that's i wish i was 160 that would be so
that'd be so then i am very strong
um just like in general but i i need to
lose weight
and i'm going to i'm on i'm on track
i've lost
15 pounds in the last two years so i'm
trying to like
speed it up um
abba and preached unfit and fresh on
marriage yeah i can react to that
why are people asking about my physical
health um
because i react to kevin samuels so
that's what they do on the show
i don't really care though if people
know like i'm really not that
it's not that serious like i'm i'm in
shape i ran like
eight miles the other day i just eat
like trash
react at two seed i have no idea who the
rapper young poppy is i don't know
um it's possible that i've reacted to
his songs before and i just like
didn't remember his name but
my true redhead um if you consider this
red hair which i would
but some people say like strawberry
blonde but yeah this is my natural hair
undead chronic i've never heard of him
your youtube videos got very random no
that's very true
um i know i was doing the music
reactions
um
the but i just literally got so sick of
it
but honestly like it kind of goes into
like black culture a little bit which is
what
seems to like do well on my account
would i ever consider calling into kevin
samuel's
show um
it depends like for what because i don't
really the only caveat where i disagree
with him is cheating
um outside of that
like i don't disagree with him on much
because in my opinion like you can
you know women and men both have like
urges but that doesn't mean you should
just like do whatever you want
um and like i believe like a lot of
those decisions can be at the cost of
your soul
um but no i would definitely
like call in if there was something like
just ask some questions
dm me undead chronic a video that i
should react to
um
i'm cheating i think he's saying
what he's been told by high value man i
also don't like how the manosphere calls
every single man
a beta or an average guy like if a guy's
in the top like 80
or seven like 60 70 and 80 percent of
guys isn't he above
average um
he's done cheating
men have 15 more testosterone and a
higher sex drive we were made to sleep
with a lot of women
um i mean yeah you that might be your
natural
inclination but you could also say like
people have like the natural inclination
to like steal
murder like there's a lot of negative
things that you could say that we are
naturally inclined to do
every like human has a dark side and i
truly believe that but that doesn't mean
like you should just act on it
um and i don't think it's cheating if
you like have an agreement
with the person you're with
and i know it's possible because
i also know it's possible because my dad
is considered like a high value man like
he's made
six figures plus um
cents and i know this is what irritates
me about the mannose fear this is what
irritates me about the man of sphere
if i say my dad doesn't cheat everyone
will argue and say oh he does you just
don't know
and that's that's what irritates me
about the mannose fear
um so
but yeah that's what i was gonna say my
dad like has made six figures
like my entire life like he's they sold
their company for
over like 20 mil like
over that like i don't know the exact
number but they sold it for a lot
and he doesn't cheat so
your dad definitely cheated at least
once no my dad doesn't drink
or go to bars so you have to understand
like this is what irritates me is people
just think because it happened in their
life
that like everyone does it but literally
like
if you eliminate like poor decisions
um like and eliminate yourself
like from environments like that
um
you avoid a lot of like temptation
i know that's what i'm saying is there's
and this is what i mean when i
watch like the like fast lifestyle in
the rich life there's two types of like
high value men and millionaires
and this is what i mean there is a type
that worked their way up through
corporate america
and that's a very different lifestyle
than like starting a concrete
company in the suburbs like those like
someone who worked their way up in
corporate america like kevin samuels
went through sales um
like you know what i mean like you're
put in environments that are like very
tempting and like very like you know
everyone's got the
like nice clothes nice cars nice
everything like
half the millionaires that i know and my
family knows you would not know that
they're millionaires like
the lady that cleans our house their
family has like hella money
like literally like and and in her free
time she like cleans our house
like isn't that nuts um
and they're like very very wealthy very
well off
um my dad could
like you guys aren't wrong that he could
but
usually at some point that stuff like
tends to come out especially
um with social media it's a lot harder
to get away with stuff like look at bill
gates
he has all the money in the world and he
couldn't hide his mistress not forever
anyway
like my dad literally is so obsessed
with like his business that he doesn't
like he's literally never and he doesn't
drink and that's like a big thing
if you don't drink
if your dad was already married when he
sold yeah my dad but my dad's been like
pretty wealthy like he's been a
millionaire since he was
very like i would guess like 30s
ish
um
yeah but like bill gates probably didn't
want the sexual allegations to come out
from
his company and stuff
and again he hit it for a long time but
the truth tends to come out
like people in the like general public
may not have known about his mistress
but i bet you people in their circles
did
and like i bet you if you asked people
at microsoft that um
bill gates hat like was a creep i bet he
was known as that
drinking doesn't make you cheat it
doesn't make you cheap but if you're
putting yourself in situations where
you're drinking it in front of
attractive like women
you're more likely to cheat it's like
you're more like did you know the
majority of murders
are like committed by people that are
under the influence of alcohol
people do things they wouldn't normally
do when they're drinking
saying women try to control me
did i no that's what i said bill gates
did spend a weekend with his girlfriend
every summer that's what i was talking
about
why wouldn't he hide it no but what i'm
saying is that the truth comes out
eventually in most cases not saying
always not saying 100 of the time but
even like
like um john f kennedy before he was
shot people know that he had a mistress
of marilyn monroe
they might not have evidence they might
not might not know for sure but it was
known that he was
that's the most powerful wealthy family
in the world
people like the truth comes out at some
point
um do you think you could be
married to a high value man and be a
traditional wife
not if that included um
i can't do cheating like that would i i
get too jealous
that so if you guys think that like
cheating
has to come with high value men then no
thank you for the donation but at the
same time though i'm gonna tell you this
um
like my dream is literally to be married
to someone and like do youtube
so that that's my dream is to have kids
and have a youtube
channel and also do like music shows on
the weekend when i have time
um
if a woman's in a relationship do you
think she should be allowed to go to
girls night out
in the clubs um not
really like i think relationship is
different than married like if you've
been dating a guy for two weeks
does he have a right to do that no but
like
um
but no i don't think girl like you
should be going out to like two three in
the morning in a relationship
um
people are
let's see if a woman is so
people are overvaluing high value men
well i don't even think
that like i mean according
according to the manosphere right like
manosphere
content i don't think that you guys
would say that i qualify because i'm not
super thin i'm not super like crazy hot
so i mean like
i'm not i'm not saying like trying to
put myself down i'm just saying
um that according to you guys that's
what you would say
um do you need everything on your
checklist to consider marriage with a
man or just most of it
um no i wouldn't say you need every
single thing
because especially when you're tall
that's like a lot harder to like
find because i'm six foot
they're overvaluing high value man i
mean it's all
comes down to the person what they
consider valuable
like for example one thing that wouldn't
have been like on a checklist
that my boyfriend like i really like
liked about him when i met him but it
wouldn't have been like on paper on a
checklist
was that he was really goofy like me
like he was down to do like funny and
goofy stuff like that was why i liked
him
and that wasn't like a checklist like
thing on a list
um
what is the shortest hideout except um
it doesn't really matter because i have
a boyfriend
um so my boyfriend's like 6'3 so that's
like perfect
um upload my old basketball highlights
damn i should they're not very good i
wasn't crazy good
um being tall doesn't make a woman
unattractive in my opinion
right but i'm saying like you know women
that are tall tend to be attracted to
guys that are taller
heavenly opinion um
i think that guys want women that have
the same opinions as them
in my experience because a lot of people
on the channel will say that i'm like
level-headed
and like feminine but i don't consider
myself it kind of like
is unfortunate but i don't consider
myself super feminine
like i'm pretty opinionated that's why i
give my opinions on my channel
i just have opinions that tend to line
up with men which makes friendships very
hard for me because
there are girls that i genuinely like
love hanging out with and love like
doing girl stuff with but i don't agree
with like anything they think
so i like think logically like a guy but
um i'm like the bub like i'm a girl
personality like
i've never really had a lot of guy
friends and if i did they tend to be
like more feminine
um yeah if you want
if you want your youtube fan to blow up
you need to react yeah if you have um
sports funny like videos movies um
that you think would be funny um dm to
them to me on instagram it's just
probably things with a z
um i react to videos people send me on
instagram all the time it's just easier
because i don't have to go through like
millions of comments
i just go through like i accept the
instagram dm
um
an earlier video you mentioned ambition
what if a man is ambition
but doesn't succeed okay so this comes
into a world view
right um my dad worked 70 to 80 hours a
week my whole life like he's the hardest
working person that i know on this
planet
my dad like i literally like look up to
him so much
and in my opinion if you put 70 80 hours
a week
into something that you want to do
whether it's writing
music you will succeed at it and
i'm not saying you'll make six figures
or succeed like heavily but
it if people do that and they don't get
impatient like they do that for like i
like maybe bite the bullet for five
years make like no money
like by the end of the five years i bet
you they make money
um
and that's what i mean like
like uh my boyfriend like it looks like
he blew up overnight and he did
but he made like 5 000 videos before he
like
blew up blew up and like made it you
know got rich basically
um
nba do you think so i have a boyfriend
so
you get it as much as you put out simple
yeah and that's what i'm saying i'm not
saying like every single person
like a lot of people say they're
ambitious and hard workers but they
don't put in the hours
and like that's what i'm saying as it's
like a mindset and it's how you look at
the world
so i that's like i genuinely believe
um that if you work hard at something
like
you improve and you make more money over
time if a man is super ambitious about
being a painter and still doesn't crack
100k woman will still look over him
yeah but like how long has he been a
painter for
um and honestly like
like if you give him like five like five
years of being a painter and then he
wants to start his own company i bet he
could crack 100k
and that's what i'm saying is it
literally takes
time and hours and i know it because
i've seen my dad
like build generational wealth
and he worked my entire life like i
barely saw my dad growing up
and he
because he just worked so freaking hard
he wasn't like the smartest person he
didn't have a college degree
but he just like worked his ass off
if you have a man that works hard it's
more security to know
if he's hurt he'll do what he can to
provide for the family yeah and that's
just like
problem solving you know
do you still dislike myron gaines is
that my
i wish i could interview my dad and put
him on my like channel but he hates
social media
um i don't like that i don't know what
his name is but the super jacked like
more dominant guy from fit fresh and fit
he just like comes off as like a snake
to me
and i mean he's like fine
um like i'd be nice to him if like i met
him or something but like
i just it's not my type of person like
the fast miami life
like i prefer like not that
college is a scam yeah i agree
um do you looking to build generational
wealth
um yeah um family traditions
i would say yes yes um do i want to
raise my own kids or have a nanny again
um
i probably will hire help for like
something if i can
like if i can afford it um maybe just
for like cleaning so i'm like actually
pretty messy
but i would